The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, on Tuesday
we talked about sex,
so today we're going
to talk about marriage.
Now, in terms of
graph theory, marriage
is expressed as a
matching problem,
and today we're going to talk
about a matching algorithm that
is used in all sorts
of applications.
It's used by online
dating agencies
to match compatible
people together.
It's used for
assignment problems,
for example, matching interns
to hospitals on match day.
It's used for resource
allocation problems,
for example, load balancing
traffic on the internet.
And we'll talk about
the applications
at the end of class.
In its simplest form
of a matching problem,
you have a graph where the
edges represent compatibility.
Two nodes can be paired
together, or married,
and the goal is to
create the maximum number
of compatible pairs.
So let's define a
matching, given a graph, G,
with nodes, V, and
edges, E. In matching,
you can think of it as
a collection of edges,
or a subgraph of G where
every node has degree 1.
So everybody can be
married just to one person.
So let's draw an example,
maybe not put that edge in.
And let's label these nodes x1,
x2, x3, x4, x5, x6, x7, and x8.
Now x1, x6 and x2, x5 is a
matching, so x1, x6 and x2,
x5 is a matching with two edges,
so we say it has size two.
All right, so I can pair these
guys up and pair these guys up.
Is there any bigger
matching in this graph?
So I found one with
two marriages, here
and here, two edges.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: x1, x7.
PROFESSOR: x1, x7.
AUDIENCE: x2, x6.
PROFESSOR: x2, x6.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
All right, that's a
matching of size three.
So I got three couples together.
Good.
Can I make a bigger matching,
one with size four--
four marriages here?
No.
Why not?
Can anybody give me a
reason why it can't be done?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: x8 and x7 would have
to be matched with someone.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if-- Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They could
only be paired with x1,
but x1 can't be
paired with both.
PROFESSOR: Good.
If I were to have a
matching with four edges,
well, there's only
eight nodes, so I'd
have to have all eight nodes
involved in the matching.
And that means x7 and x8 would
have to be in the matching,
but they could only
be paired with x1,
and so it's not
possible to do that.
All right, so there
is no matching
of size four in this graph.
Three is the best I can do.
Now, when you get every
node in a matching,
then it's called a
perfect matching.
And so in this case, it doesn't
exist, but sometimes it does.
So a matching is
perfect if it has
size half the number of nodes.
In other words, if the
number of edges is v over 2,
then every node is
in the matching.
All right, so that one doesn't
have a perfect matching.
What about this graph?
So I got b1, b2, b3,
b4, g1, g2, g3, g4,
and I'll put in the
compatibility edges here.
OK, Does that graph
have a perfect matching?
Can you pair up
every boy with a girl
here so that everybody is
compatible with their mate,
and you have just one spouse?
Can you do that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
All right, who do
I start pairing up?
AUDIENCE: 1, 1.
AUDIENCE: b2, g3.
PROFESSOR: b2, g3.
AUDIENCE: b3, g2.
PROFESSOR: b3, g2
AUDIENCE: b4, g4.
PROFESSOR: There we go.
All right, so there is a
perfect matching in this graph.
Very good.
Now, in some cases,
some pairings
are more desirable than
others, and this can
be represented with a weight.
And so you might have
a weighted graph where
every edge has a weight on it.
For example, we might
weight b1, g2 with 5,
and b1, g1 gets a 10.
And usually when you
see weighted graphs
in the matching
context, a lower weight
means it's more desirable, so
that b1 and g2 would get along
better than b1 and g1.
And then the goal is to find a
matching with minimum weight.
Now, the weight of a
matching, call it M,
is the sum of the weights
on the edges of M. Now,
usually when you're looking
at weighted matchings,
you require yourself to
have a perfect matching so
that everybody gets paired up.
And often in that case, you'll
see all the edges present,
some of them with very big
weights, maybe even infinity
if they just can't
be put together.
Because otherwise you just say,
don't match anybody together,
and you have weight zero.
So for when you look at
minimum weight matchings,
you're looking for the perfect
matching with minimum weight.
So we say a min-weight
matching for a graph, G,
is a perfect matching for
G with the minimum weight,
overall perfect matchings.
Let's try an example.
Say I've got this graph,
and call this node Brad,
here's Billy Bob, here's
Jennifer, and then Angelina.
And the weights are as
follows-- I put a 10 here,
a 10 down here, a 5
here, because Brad really
likes Angelina and vice versa,
and a 16 between Jennifer
and Billy Bob.
What is the weight of the min
weight matching in that graph?
20.
And who gets paired
with who there?
Who does Brad get
hooked up with?
AUDIENCE: Jan.
PROFESSOR: Jan, and that
leaves Billy Bob with Angelina,
and the weight is 20.
So even though Brad really likes
Angelina, if I go that route,
my weight is 21,
which is not as good.
So the min-weight matching
would be this one.
OK.
Now, it turns out that
finding the maximum matching--
the maximum number of edges
you can put together--
or finding the minimum
weight perfect matching,
those are both solvable,
tractable problems.
You don't get a million
dollar prize for solving that.
The algorithm is run in
quadratic to cubic time,
so not terrible, but
they're not NP-complete,
so people know how to do it.
Now, they are
pretty complicated,
so we're not going to
cover them in 6042.
What we're going to do is look
at a slightly different version
of the problem that
actually turns out
to be more useful in
practice, because there's
a very nice algorithm for it.
Now, in the version of
the problem that we're
going to look at, everybody
has preferences-- a preference
list.
It's not weighted, but
it's a priority order
of who they want to get
mated to, or matched up with.
So it would look
not quite like that,
but it would look like this.
So Brad, Billy Bob, Jennifer,
and Angelina-- same players,
but what we do is we know that
Brad really likes Angelina,
and Angelina really likes Brad,
so they are first choices,
at least was.
Number two for Brad is Jennifer,
but Jennifer really likes Brad
first, and Billy Bob second.
Billy Bob likes Angelina
first, then Jennifer.
Angelina thinks Billy
Bob is number two.
So it's not
necessarily symmetric.
Jennifer has Brad
as the first choice.
Brad has Angelina
All right?
So it's an asymmetric situation.
Now, what would happen if we set
up our marriages so that Brad
is married to Jen, and Billy
Bob is married to Angelina?
What might happen if we
made those as our pairings,
and we put them on a desert
island, all four of them?
What's likely to happen there?
AUDIENCE: Brad and Angelina are
going to cheat on each other.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we're
going to have a problem.
Because Brad and Angelina have
the hots for each other here,
and they like each other
better than their spouse.
So before you know
it, they're going
to be doing their 6042 homework
together late at night.
All right?
Now, when this happens, we have
what's called a rogue couple.
Given a matching, x and
y, a boy and a girl,
say, form a rogue couple
if they prefer each other
over their mates
in M. All right.
So here, if we married
Brad to Jennifer,
and Billy Bob to Angelina,
Brad and Angelina
form a rogue
couple, because they
like each other better than
who they were hooked up with.
And that's sort of a bad thing.
It creates instability
if you were
to make the matchings that way.
In fact, we say that
a matching is stable
if there aren't
any rogue couples.
And now, one thing to make
clear is that your preferences
can't change over time.
So it's not a situation where
you get bored with your spouse,
and you change
your mind, and then
you go off and create
a rogue couple.
You're fixed in your
preferences over all time,
no playing the field, none
of that stuff here, OK?
So it's fixed once and for
all, and your goal, of course,
is to create or find a perfect
matching that's stable.
That's the goal.
So get everybody married
up and make it stable.
All right, is it
doable in that example?
If I put those four
people on a desert island,
could I make a stable matching?
Yeah, who would I match Brad to?
AUDIENCE: Angelina.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Good, and then Billy
Bob gets Jennifer.
Now, I'm not saying that
you make everybody happy,
because Billy Bob and Jennifer
are probably not happy there.
They each got their
number two choice.
But it's stable, because
Brad and Angelina
aren't going anywhere.
They are going to stay
together because they
like each other best, and so
there's no chance that Jennifer
is going to-- that Angelina
is going to sneak off, sorry,
with Billy Bob, or
that Brad's going
to sneak off with Jennifer.
All right?
So it's stable.
Not everybody's happy, but
it's a stable set of marriages.
OK.
Any questions about what
we're trying to do here now?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the edges?
PROFESSOR: That's
a great question.
You'll see it
referred to both ways.
Technically, it's a subgraph,
so it has nodes and edges,
but you'll see me, and you'll
see everybody say, oh, it's
a bunch of edges that
don't share any nodes,
and you'll see them
refer to it as the edges.
But really, underlying that,
it's a subgraph, technically.
Any other questions
about what we're
trying to do here to find
stable, perfect matching?
All right.
Well, in this example, there
was a stable, perfect matching.
But what about in general?
If I have a lot more
people, and they
have arbitrary preferences,
how many people
think you can always find
a stable perfect matching?
There's one optimistic person.
How many people think there's
some cases where you're just
not going to be able to do it?
Wow.
OK, it's a pessimistic view.
Well, in some sense
you're both right.
If you allow boys to prefer
boys and girls to prefer girls,
then it is not possible, and
I'll give you an example.
You can find examples where
there's always a rogue couple,
but if you require boys to only
get matched to girls and vice
versa, then it is possible to
always find stable marriages,
stable matchings.
And we're going to talk
about an algorithm for that.
But before I show
you the algorithm,
let me show you the bad case
when boys can prefer boys,
or what's sort of
a unisex scenario.
So here's a bad example
with four people,
and the idea is to
create a love triangle.
So we have Alex, who prefers
Bobby Joe, Bobby Joe prefers
Robin, and Robin prefers Alex.
And their second choices
go in the opposite order
there, all right?
So Alex wants to
be with Bobby Joe.
Bobby Joe wants be with Robin.
Robin wants to be with Alex.
And then there's Mergatoid--
[LAUGHTER]
--and nobody likes Mergatoid.
So that's choice three
for all of them here.
And Mergatoid's
choices, preferences
don't really matter
in this case.
[LAUGHTER]
I hope nobody is named
Mergatoid in the class.
I would get complaints here.
All right, so I want
to claim and prove
a theorem that says there
is no stable matching
for this group of preferences.
So we'll state that
as the theorem.
There does not exist a stable
matching for this graph.
The proof is by contradiction--
assume there is one.
All right, so assume there
exists a stable matching.
We're going to find
a rogue couple in it.
So call the stable
matching M. Well,
if there's a stable
matching, Mergatoid's got
to get married to somebody.
Mergatoid will be
matched with someone.
All right.
Now, here I'm going
to do something
that you can do in
your proofs, but you've
got to be careful
when you do it.
I'm going to say, without
loss of generality,
assume Mergatoid is
matched to Alex, all right?
And I can do that.
So this is the
abbreviation, without loss
of generality by symmetry.
And really, I should explain
what I mean here in the proof.
Well, that love
triangle is symmetric.
Each one has a preference
for the next person
around the triangle.
In terms of graph isomorphism,
with the weights on that,
every node looks the same.
So I can use symmetry.
So we're going to say,
without loss of generality,
we're going to assume
Mergatoid is matched to Alex.
And I'm implying the argument
is going to be the same.
What I say next is
the same no matter
who Mergatoid is matched
to, because it's symmetric.
All right.
If Mergatoid is
matched to Alex, do you
see a rogue couple up there?
So you have Robin
matched to Bobby Joe.
Mergatoid is matched to Alex.
AUDIENCE: Alex to Bobby Joe?
PROFESSOR: Alex
and Bobby Joe, no.
AUDIENCE: Between
Alex and Robin.
PROFESSOR: Alex and Robin, yeah.
Alex and Bobby Joe aren't rogue,
because Bobby Joe likes Robin.
He likes the person he
or she is married to.
All right, so they're not
going to go off with Alex,
but Alex and Robin
are a rogue couple,
because Robin likes Alex
the best, and Alex for sure
likes Robin better
than Mergatoid.
All right?
So they both prefer each
other to their mates,
and so they form a rogue couple.
All right, so Alex and
Robin form a rogue couple,
and that means that
M was not stable.
The matching was not stable.
And that's a contradiction,
because we assumed it was.
So we have a contradiction,
and the proof is done.
Any questions about that?
And I'm sort of implying
here that you could match,
you could have had Mergatoid
matched to Bobby Joe,
and then Bobby Joe and Alex
would have been a rogue couple,
or Mergatoid matched to Robin,
and then Robin and Bobby Joe
would be a rogue couple by the
without loss of generality.
So it's OK to use that,
but you want to be careful
that you're doing it OK.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the without
loss of generality only
works if it's, like,
perfectly symmetric?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Basically, the argument
you're going to make
is just going to be the same
argument done in all three
cases, and to save yourself
some effort, you're saying,
don't do the three cases,
do one, the other two look
the same.
So technically, you could add
case one, case two, case three,
and they would've
looked symmetric.
OK?
All right.
Now, this is not very
surprising, as you all voted.
Almost all of you said it's
hard to find stable matchings.
You might not be
able to do it always.
And in fact, you can't
in the unisex world.
The surprising thing is, you can
always find a stable matching
in the world where boys
could only be paired
with girls and vice versa.
Now, this statement, this
result is pretty famous.
The problem itself is known as
the stable marriage problem.
So let me just define
it here, and then we'll
talk about an algorithm
to find the matching.
So we have N boys and N girls.
And it's important we have
the same number of each.
Now, actually, tomorrow,
in recitation, you're
going to look at the
scenario where there's more
girls than boys, or vice versa.
And you'll be using
a similar algorithm,
but it'll be a
different context,
and that's the
context that comes up
in matching interns to
hospitals, and stuff like that.
But for our version it's an
equal number of boys and girls.
Each boy has his own
ranked preference
list of all the girls.
So every boy sort of
has his dance card
of the girls that
he likes in order.
All right?
The orders can be different
for different boys.
And each girl has
the same thing.
She has her own list, ranked
1 to n of all the boys.
The lists are complete,
and there's no ties,
so all the ties have
to be broken here.
And the goal is to
find a perfect matching
without rogue couples.
OK, so let's try an example.
Before we do the algorithm,
let me just do a bigger example
with five boys and
five girls, and we'll
get some feel for, this is
not completely obvious how
to find it.
OK, so let's put
the boys over here.
And here's boy 1, and
his preference list
is going to be-- the girls
will be C, B, E, A, D, and boy
2 is going to have
the preference list
A, B, E, C, D, and boy 3 is
going to have D, C, B, A, E.
Boy 4 is going to be A,
C, D, B, E, and boy 5,
I have to write his across
like this, A, B, D, E, C.
And the girls also have their
lists, so let's put those up.
So girl A likes the boys
in order 3, 5, 2, 1, 4.
Girl B likes them in
order 5, 2, 1, 4, 3.
Girl C has the
order 4, 3, 5, 1, 2.
Girl D, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
and then the last girl, E,
has 2, 3, 4, 1, 5.
All right, so say that's
our matching problem,
and those are the
preference lists.
Any ideas for how we might
try to make an algorithm
to do this?
Any thoughts about
what you'd do?
What are some approaches
we could take?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Use the
mating algorithm.
PROFESSOR: Use the
greedy algorithm?
AUDIENCE: The mating algorithm.
PROFESSOR: Oh, the
mating algorithm.
Well, yeah, the mating algorithm
is going to do very well,
but I haven't told
you what that is,
and it's a little complicated.
So I sort of want to explore
the things you might know
from what we've done so far.
What approaches have we seen
so far for solving problems?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The greedy algorithm?
PROFESSOR: The greedy
algorithm-- yep.
And let's try that.
So let's choose the
first boy, and we'll just
go down and give each boy
the best choice available
and see what happens.
First thing to try usually
is the greedy algorithm,
and about half the time
it'll work in life,
and half the time it won't.
So let's try greedy.
So boy 1 is going to get his
first choice, girl C. Who
does boy 2 get?
A. Who does boy 3 get?
D. Huh, this is going well.
Who does boy 4 get?
Boy 4, oh yeah, boy 4 has got
to go all the way down to B,
because A, C, and D
got taken, so boy 4
gets B. And boy 5-- who's left?
E, fourth choice again.
All right, well, maybe
that's a stable matching.
All right, well let's see.
To see if it's stable,
we've got to see
are there any rogue couples.
Well, is there any rogue
couple involving boy 1?
No, boy 1 got his first choice.
You're not going anywhere.
Boy 2?
No-- first choice,
same with boy 3.
These boys are quite happy.
They're not doing anything.
Boy 4 may not be
so happy though,
because boy 4 got paired
with B, so there's
possible rogue couples.
Let's see, is 4,
A a rogue couple?
No.
A hates boy 4, all right?
No chance she's
running off with boy 4.
AUDIENCE: 4, C?
PROFESSOR: 4, C?
All right, let's see that.
Where's C-- whoa, yeah.
C has the hots for
boy 4, so she likes
him better than
whoever her mate was,
and boy 4 likes C better
than who he got matched with,
boy B. That is now
a rogue couple,
so the greedy
algorithm did not work.
That's too bad.
Well, it would be short
lecture, I guess, if it worked.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, what would you do next,
sort of, if you were-- I mean,
you could try to match 4 with
C, and then try to patch things
up, and you could
start doing that,
but you might create
other rogue couples.
In fact, I don't know
an approach-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could
let it evolve and see
if it gets it more stable.
PROFESSOR: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: You could
let it evolve,
let all the rogue
couples evolve and see
if it ends up any more stable.
PROFESSOR: Yes, you could
start swapping around
to get rid of rogue couples.
In doing that, you might
create other rogue couples.
In fact, I don't know
of an algorithm that
works like this, that
works, that's known to work,
where you start
patching things up,
because as you're
you might make other things
much worse by doing that.
So I don't know of
an approach that way.
What's another approach?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
pertaining to what order
they have each other.
PROFESSOR: And then do?
AUDIENCE: And then do the
highest ordered [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Min-weight
matching kind of thing?
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
PROFESSOR: Maybe?
I don't of an approach
like that that works.
Also, min-weight
matching, that algorithm
is going to be more
complicated than the one I'm
going to show you, in the end.
It takes more time to run.
And I don't even
know if it works.
Like, I don't know if you
can take these numbers
and make weights on the edges
get a min-weight matching.
AUDIENCE: Could you do like
a merge sort [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, a merge sort,
so you take the minimum weight
edge, put that in, and
recurse on that kind of thing.
I don't know.
It's possible.
In fact, you know what,
a recursive approach
is a good idea.
I don't know of a nice
recursive algorithm for this.
It's true that if you
found a boy and a girl who
liked each other
best, you could then
match them safely and recurse,
because you know they're not
going to be in a rogue
couple, because they
like each other best.
Then you could recurse.
But that might not exist here.
You might not have
a boy and girl
that like each other best, in
which case it's hard to know.
I don't know now if you pick the
minimum weight in some sense,
like add the preference list or
something to make a min-weight
and recurse on
that, if that works.
I don't know of an
approach like that.
But those are the kinds
of things you try.
And as far as I know,
all the simple things
fail for this problem.
But there is something that's
a little more involved,
but does work, and that's
the mating algorithm.
And does everybody
have the handout?
There, it's back up there.
I got some copies down here if
you need it, but pull that out.
So we're going to
read this and talk
about what the
algorithm is, and then
prove that it performs well.
So the initial condition is
you have each of the N boys
has an ordered list of the
N girls and vice versa,
and the ritual, we're going to
view this is a mating ritual,
and really, the
program is doing it.
The code is doing it.
But think of it as real life.
It takes place
over several days.
Now, the day is broken up into
three parts-- the morning,
the afternoon, and the evening.
In the morning, each girl
comes out to her balcony
and stands on the balcony.
Each boy goes to the balcony
of his favorite girl who
is still on his list that
hasn't been crossed off.
Now, initially, every
girl is on his list.
So he goes to his favorite
girl, goes under her balcony,
and serenades her.
Now, if, over the
course of the algorithm,
the boy has nobody left on
his list, he's out of luck.
He just stays home
and does homework.
All right?
There's no serenade
anymore for him.
Now, in the afternoon,
the girls who
have at least one suitor--
a boy down there serenading
her-- looks at all the
suitors, picks her favorite,
and to the favorite she
says, maybe I'll marry you.
Come back tomorrow.
Girls don't want to make it
too easy here for the boys.
Now, to all the other boys who
are lower priority she says,
I will never marry you.
Go away.
So she writes them off for good.
Now, that night, any boy who
heard a no-- like the girl
said no, I'll never marry you--
crosses that girl off his list.
Because, you know, it's
the only practical thing
to do at that point.
Now, if the boy heard
the maybe I'll marry you,
well, he's going to
go back tomorrow,
because that's still
his favorite girl that's
not crossed off.
So he goes back and
serenades her again
the next day in the hopes that
eventually, she'll say yes.
Now, we keep doing
this every day, OK?
And if we ever encounter a
day where every girl has,
at most, one suitor, the
algorithm stops, and then
every girl who has a suitor
says, yes, I will marry you.
Now, if a girl
doesn't have a suitor,
there's no one to marry her.
We're going to prove
that doesn't happen, OK?
But determination
condition is, you no longer
have a situation with two or
more boys under one balcony.
OK?
All right, so let's run that
algorithm on this example,
just so we make sure
we understand it,
because I'm going to try
to prove theorems about it.
So here are the serenades
that are going on,
and here's the
girls, and the days.
It's going to work over
four days in this case.
And then we're also going to
keep track of the boy's lists--
who's gotten crossed off.
All right, so these will be
the cross outs down here.
Actually, maybe I'll
fit it up here if I can.
Girls, let's see, A, B-- no, I'm
going to have to space it out.
And the boys have
their lists here,
and we have boys 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And here I'm going to
record the cross outs.
All right, so let's
look at day one.
Who is under girl A's
balcony on day one?
AUDIENCE: 2, 4, and 5?
PROFESSOR: 2, 4, and 5--
each like girl A the best,
so she's got a lot of activity.
These three boys show up.
Anybody under girl B's balcony?
No, nope, no, nothing there.
C, does C have anybody?
Boy 1, yeah.
D?
3, and E, I don't think
there's any action, right?
Nope.
All right, so that's
the status on day one.
So the action is all up here.
All right, so what
does girl A do?
Who does she tell
to hang around?
AUDIENCE: Number 5.
PROFESSOR: Number 5, yes.
She's got 5, 4, and 2,
and she likes 5 the best.
She tells 5 to come back,
and she says to these guys,
we're not going to marry him.
That means that boys 2 and 4
cross girl A off their list.
So they say A is no
longer possible for them.
All right, now we go to
day two, and 5 goes back
to girl A, and, of course,
boys 1 and 3 stay there.
Where does boy 2 go on day two?
B.
All right, so boy 2
shows up here on day two,
and, let's see, boy
5 is already there,
and then we've got to get boy 4.
Where does he go now?
C. All right, boy
4 shows up here.
All right, so now the
action is with girl C.
And what does she do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, she keeps
4, and she boots poor 1.
You know, led him
along for a day,
and then he gets the boot
because boy 4 showed up, right?
Because girl C likes 4
better than 1, so bad
luck for 1 there.
So now one goes home that
night and crosses off girl C.
OK.
All right, and where
does 1 go on day three?
All right, so he goes to-- he
crossed off C-- he goes to B.
All right, so this is left over.
We have 5, 2, 4, 3-- boy
1 now goes to B, right?
OK.
And then what does girl B do?
Who does she keep around?
Keeps 2, boots poor 1.
All right, so 1 says, all right,
I'm crossing B off my list,
got the message.
And now where does
boy 1 go on day four?
AUDIENCE: Girl E?
PROFESSOR: E-- third choice.
OK.
So 1 shows up down here, and
these guys keep returning.
Wow, so on day four
there's no more fighting.
Every girl has at most one.
The termination
condition is invoked,
and these are the
marriages that take place.
The girls say yes.
All right, now is everybody--
[LAUGHTER]
--does everybody understand
the algorithm we used?
Any questions on the algorithm?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
first case [INAUDIBLE] or
is that just in
case the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's in case
the algorithm doesn't work.
Because we haven't
proved it works yet,
and I gotta have
a possibility for,
a boy crosses every
girl off his list,
he gets rejected everywhere.
That is a possibility,
so I've got
to say what would happen
in that possibility.
Now, we will prove
in a few minutes
that condition never arises, OK?
But I'm giving you
what might happen,
in which so it never
does, so no boy ends up
having to stay home
and do homework here.
All right, so that's
the algorithm.
Now let's see if we can see
if there's any rogue couples.
All right, so, for example,
let's look at boy 1.
Boy 1 got paired to his
third choice, E, so 1,
C might be a rogue couple.
Is that possible?
No, because C got 4 here,
which is her first choice.
She's not going with boy 1.
That's not working.
What about 1, B?
Could that be rogue?
No, B got 2, and B likes 2
better than 1, so 1, C and 1,
B are not rogue.
And 1 got E, so there's no
other possibility for boy 1,
so boy 1 is not
in a rogue couple.
What about boy 2?
2 got B, and that's
2's second choice.
What about 2, A?
Let's see, A got 5, and
A likes 5 better than 2,
so that's not rogue.
Boy 2 is not rogue.
All right, boy 3-- boy 3
got his first choice, right?
3 got D, so 3 is
not going anywhere.
Boy 4 got-- who did boy 4 get--
got C. 4 got his second choice.
What about 4, A?
A hates 4.
A is not gonna get caught dead
with 4, so that's not rogue.
So 4 is OK.
4 is not in a rogue couple.
And finally, boy 5--
boy 5 is paired with A,
and that is boy
5's first choice,
so he's not wandering off here.
All right?
So in fact, we've
just argued that this
is a stable set of marriages,
a stable matching in this case.
Any questions now about
what we're trying to do?
OK, because we're going
to try to show now
it always produces
a stable matching.
And to do that, we need
to do a few things.
All right, so what
are the things
we need to show to
prove everything
is going to be good here?
What are some facts we to prove?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Don't we need to show
that the algorithm, it does
come to an end?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
The algorithm
terminates, so we need
to show that the marriage
algorithm, TMA, terminates.
Otherwise, the boys
are serenading forever,
and that's not too good.
All right, what else
do we want to show?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If it does terminate,
then one is left empty.
PROFESSOR: Then?
AUDIENCE: Everyone gets someone.
PROFESSOR: Everyone
gets married.
Yep.
Stability is easy if
nobody gets married.
All right, what else do
we want to show here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There are
no rogue couples.
PROFESSOR: No rogue couples.
All right, what else
might we like to show?
These are the three main ones.
There's a couple of other
things you might like.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It runs quickly.
PROFESSOR: It runs quickly.
Well, you can only
serenade for so long.
In fact, it does run
quickly, and that's
why it's useful in practice.
Anything else you might want
to show about this algorithm?
AUDIENCE: How many
people you crossed out?
PROFESSOR: How many people
you crossed out-- yeah,
you could, and that'll tie
into how long it takes.
Yeah.
Anything else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The average
likeness between the couples.
PROFESSOR: The
average likeness, oh.
So yeah, we haven't
had a notion here
of how happy people
are at the end,
because we don't have a
weighting on the edges,
but you might want
to think about that.
That's actually a good point.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If they
[INAUDIBLE] if it
matters who serenades
[INAUDIBLE] girls or boys
to get her.
PROFESSOR: That's a great point.
Is this algorithm good for
girls, or good for boys?
Yeah, that's a good
point-- fairness.
All right, so we'll take
a look at fairness also.
Is it better to be a serenader,
or be on the balcony making
your choices?
OK, so this is what
we've got to do.
So let's start by
showing TMA terminates,
and that it terminates
pretty quickly.
Now, in fact, I'm going to
prove a fairly crude bound
on the time, but it
actually does fairly well.
So our first theorem
is going to be
that TMA terminates in, at
most, N squared plus 1 days.
N is the number
of boys and girls.
The proof is going to
be by contradiction.
This is probably
the only day where
we'll do a bunch of proofs and
none of them use induction.
They're pretty much
all by contradiction.
Suppose TMA does not terminate
in N squared plus 1 days,
because we're going to show
that leads to a contradiction.
We need to show that
some kind of progress
is made each day to
show that it terminates.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
number of causes that have
[INAUDIBLE], so if it
has not terminated,
then at least one girl is seeing
a group of at least one guy--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --so the number
of crosses cannot be defined
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Very good.
OK, let's state that
as a claim, and you've
given the proof of the
claim, which is great.
If we don't terminate,
on a day, that
must be because a girl had two
boys there, or more, therefore
she rejected some, at least one.
And that night, the rejected
boy crosses a girl off his list.
So if we don't terminate,
then at least one boy
crosses at least one
girl off his list.
And so we're going to measure
progress by the cross outs.
So every day we don't
terminate, a boy
crossed a girl off his list,
so if we didn't terminate
at N squared plus
1 days, we must
have crossed off N squared plus
1 girls across all the lists.
Well, is that possible?
To have done N squared
plus 1 cross outs?
What do you think?
How many names are on each list?
AUDIENCE: N.
PROFESSOR: N, and how
many lists are there?
AUDIENCE: N.
PROFESSOR: N, so there's N
lists with N names implies
there's, at most, N
squared cross outs ever.
But we just said we had N
squared plus 1 cross outs.
But we have also N
squared plus 1 cross outs,
and that's a contradiction.
All right?
So we're done.
It has to terminate within
N squared plus 1 days.
Any questions?
This is a very common proof
technique in computer science.
You're analyzing some
system, and every step
or every day or
every time period,
you want to argue
progress got made,
and then after you've
made enough progress you
have to be done, and therefore,
the algorithm is completed.
All right, so we know
that TMA terminates.
Now, we've still got
to get everyone married
and have them all be
happy, or at least stable.
Now, to do this, we're
going to use an invariant.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If a girl
has some guy in front
of [INAUDIBLE] on
something, then she
will always have [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That is true.
Something even stronger is true.
AUDIENCE: All the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Have a--
PROFESSOR: If she has a
preference for someone who
[INAUDIBLE] only better guys.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
a great invariant.
As the girl is sitting
there on her balcony,
things only get better,
because she always
keeps the best one
around that's there.
And when new ones
come in, they've
got to be better than the
last one for her to keep them.
So as she rejects boys, she
only does that because she's
got better ones there, and
whoever she says maybe to
always comes back.
So an invariant
of this algorithm
is that when a girl has
a suitor, going forward,
she only has suitors she
likes at least as well.
And if she ever rejects
a boy, then she's
got somebody better
there forever.
All right, so let's state that
as an invariant and prove that.
OK, so we're going to let
P be our invariant here.
P is the statement that if a
girl, G, ever rejected a boy,
B, then the girl,
G, has a suitor,
or if the algorithm
is terminated,
a husband who she
prefers to B. All right,
that's going to
be our invariant,
and now we've got to
prove it's an invariant.
So we'll do that with a
lemma called lemma one.
P is an invariant for TMA.
All right, let's prove that.
Now, what's the
first thing you've
got to prove when you're proving
something as an invariant?
There's two things you've got
to do to establish a variant.
What's the first one?
AUDIENCE: Base case?
PROFESSOR: Base case.
Show it holds true
at the beginning.
Proof is going to
be by induction,
and so we've got to show that
P holds true at the beginning.
But what are we going
to induct on here?
What's the parameter
we're inducting on?
AUDIENCE: Time?
PROFESSOR: Time,
the number of days.
Good.
The base case is day
zero, the beginning.
All right.
Well, is that statement
true on day zero?
Yeah, it's true for
sort of a weird reason.
Nobody's been
rejected yet, so it's
what's called vacuously true.
Because no girl, G, has
rejected any boy, so it's true.
So no one is rejected yet.
So it's vacuously true.
All right, next we have
the induction step.
So we'll assume P holds
at the end of day d,
and we need to argue
that it holds now
at the end of day d plus 1.
So say it's true up
to now, up to day d.
Why Is it true at the
end of the next day?
Well, there's two cases
to look at here, depending
on when G rejected B. So if
she rejects B on this day, day
d plus 1, well, why would
she reject B on day d plus 1?
There's only one scenario.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There's a better boy.
PROFESSOR: There's a better boy.
And so she says maybe to him,
and he becomes her suitor.
So, in fact, P is true.
So then there was
someone better,
and that implies P is
true on day d plus 1.
Case two is very similar.
It's a very simple proof.
G rejected B before
day d, before d plus 1.
Well, now we use the fact that
P was true at the end of day
d, which means P now implies
that G had at least as good
a suitor.
Actually, it's better,
because it was rejected.
A better suitor on day d,
that's what the hypothesis says,
the invariant says.
And now we just have to look
at what happens on d plus 1.
Well, either she has the
same suitor on d plus 1,
or somebody better came along.
And so we're going to be done.
She has the same or better
suitor on day d plus 1,
and that implies P is true
on d plus 1, and we're done.
All right, so I went
through this proof.
It was sort of
obvious, but this is
the careful way
you'd write it down
to show that the
invariant holds.
Any questions about
the invariant dilemma?
All right, so things only
get better for the girls.
If she ever rejected somebody,
she's got somebody better.
So now we can prove
the main result,
that everyone is married.
And again the proof will
be by contradiction.
So we assume not
everyone was married.
Assume, for the purpose
of contradiction,
that some boy, B, we'll
call him, is not married.
Because if everyone is not
married then some boy is not.
If not everyone is married
then some boy is not married.
So when it terminates,
B is not married.
Well, what do you know
about B if he was not
married at the end?
PROFESSOR: He was
rejected by everyone.
rejected by everyone,
because if at the end,
he's still under a balcony,
if he still had somebody
on his list, he'd be there.
And he'd be getting married,
because it's the end.
So this means that
if B is not married,
he's rejected by everybody.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] list?
PROFESSOR: Oh, he's
on everybody's list.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Everybody
has everybody
of the opposite
sex on their list,
but he had to cross
everybody off.
That's true.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That would mean
that everyone had somebody
better on the same day that
[INAUDIBLE] telling him she
didn't want to be with him.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
That means that B
crossed every girl off.
B is rejected by
every girl, which
means every girl
has somebody better
than B, which is not
possible, because that would
mean every girl was married.
And therefore, the equal number
of boys and girls, that means B
would have been married.
Good.
All right, let's
write that down.
This means that B was
rejected by every girl.
OK, that means that
every girl, by lemma 1,
has a better suitor, and
that's where we use lemma 1.
And that means that
every girl is married,
and that means that every
boy is married, including B,
and that's a
contradiction, because we
said B wasn't married.
OK?
Everybody buy that proof?
Any questions about that?
Yeah, proof by contradiction
is a pretty powerful technique.
Once you assume something
is not going to be true,
it gives you a lot of power
to find a contradiction.
All right, so now we know
that the algorithm ends,
and everybody gets married.
All's we got to do is show
that there's no rogue couples,
so let's do that.
TMA produces a stable matching.
Now, how do you suppose
we're going to prove this?
What's going to be the
approach to prove this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Assume that
there's a rogue couple.
PROFESSOR: Assume that
there's a rogue couple,
that namely this is not true,
so there must be rogue couple.
So let Bob and Gail be any
pair that are not married.
I need to prove the Bob
and Gail are not rogue,
and then we'll be fine.
Because if it says everybody
who is not married is not rogue,
then we know we have
a stable matching.
Now, there's a
couple of cases here.
Bob and Gail weren't
married, so there's two ways
that could have happened.
What's one of them?
What's one reason
they might not be
married, something that happened
that made that impossible?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Gail rejected Bob.
PROFESSOR: Good.
Case one-- Gail rejected Bob.
Well, what do we know in that
case, if Gail rejected Bob?
AUDIENCE: Gail had
better suitors.
PROFESSOR: Gail has another
suitor that she likes better.
And, in fact, what do we
know about who Gail married?
AUDIENCE: Better than Bob.
PROFESSOR: Better
than Bob-- things only
get better for the girls.
That's the lemma one.
All right, so this means that
Gail marries someone that she
thinks is better than Bob.
And that's by lemma one.
Well, can Gail and Bob
be a rogue couple here?
No, because Gail likes her
spouse better than Bob,
so she's not going to be
in a rogue affair with Bob.
So that means that Gail
and Bob are not rogue.
All right, case two is
Gail did not reject Bob.
She never did.
That's the other case,
she didn't reject Bob.
Could Bob have ever
serenaded Gail in this case?
No, because if he did and
he was never rejected,
they would have
ended up married.
All right?
So that means the Bob
never serenaded Gail.
What does that mean about
how Bob feels about Gail?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Bob must have
never serenaded for Gail.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, Bob
never got far enough down
on his list to serenade Gail.
He got married before
he got down there.
All right, so that
means that Gail is lower
on Bob's list than Bob's wife.
And that means that
they're not rogue,
because Bob likes his
wife better than Gail.
All right, so in each case, the
cases clearly cover everything.
Gail rejected Bob,
or she didn't.
Either way, Gail and
Bob are not rogue.
So that means there's
no rogue couples,
and that implies M is
stable, TMA is stable.
OK?
All right, so TMA
terminates, everyone
gets married, no rogue
couples, nice outlook.
So we're done.
We actually proved it works.
One issue left to
think about here.
Any questions on that before we
launch off into the last issue?
AUDIENCE: Is it unique?
PROFESSOR: Is it unique?
TMA gives you a unique answer
because it's an algorithm.
It's deterministic.
But there may be other
stable matchings.
OK, so there's not just one
stable matching, necessarily.
You could make examples with
multiple stable matchings.
That's a great question.
Any other questions?
All right.
Oh, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there
generally any other way
to assess optimality besides
the fact that it's stable, or--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can
make up lots of them.
You could put
weights on the edges
and get a min-weight matching.
You could try to get
the perfect matching
with the least unfavorable
marriage kind of thing.
There's a lot of
criteria you can make.
This one turns out to be useful
in practice in a variety ways
that we'll talk
about, and also have
a nice, fast, simple
algorithm that can actually
run in a distributed
environment, which
is really nice.
So it is probably the
most practical approach
to matching out there.
Any other questions?
OK, the last
issue-- I don't know
if we still have the issues
up there-- is fairness.
So who thinks the TMA is
favorable to the boys?
Just a couple.
Who thinks it's
favorable to the girls?
More, that's the
common response.
Who thinks you can't even
define it one way or the other?
It's unclear and
hopeless to decide.
OK, well, it seems like
maybe the girls, because they
get the best of their suitors.
They sit back, and
they just take the best
as they come along.
On the other hand,
the boys do try
to go out and get
their first choice.
The girls have to wait.
And Mr. Right may
never come along.
The boys are out there.
I'm going to my first choice,
and they get denied, OK, they
just move right on
to the next choice.
So this is actually
one of these questions
of study in sociology.
In the animal species, which is
better, proposers or acceptors?
What's the more powerful result?
Who has the better
power in courtship?
It turns out that we can
answer this question in a very
clear way, and prove it here.
And the answer is the boys
have all the power here.
This is very favorable to
the boys, and we'll see why.
Now, to prove that, we
need some definitions.
OK, so I've got to define
a couple things here
to be able to prove this.
The first is, for any
collection of preference lists,
we're going to let S be the
set of all stable matchings.
Now, we know that S
is not empty, right?
How do we know that
S is not empty here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] stable.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because TMA
produces a stable matching,
so we know that S is not empty.
There's at least one.
And, in fact, there
could be many.
Now, for each person, P, we
define the realm of possibility
for P to be the set of
mates that you might
have in a stable matching.
So it's a set queue
of people for which
there exists a matching
that's stable such that you're
mated to that person.
So I've written this
in some-- that's
sort of complicated
mathematics, but somebody
is in your realm of possibility
if there is a stable matching
where you married them.
If it exists, there's
a stable matching
where you could marry them.
And this is vaguely like
you see sometimes, you're
going out with somebody and your
parents say, oh, they're not
in your league, or something.
This is a mathematical
formulation
for that, that there is some way
in the world to marry everybody
up, so it's all
stable, and you could
be married to that person.
OK?
Let's do an example
with four people.
All right, so for example, say
we have Brad, Jen, and Angelina
again.
And of course Brad likes
Angelina and vice versa.
Gen likes Brad, and then
there's Billy Bob here.
All right.
Now, Brad is not
realistic for Jen.
Brad Is not in Jen's
realm of possibility,
because in any perfect matching
where Brad marries Jen,
you're going to
have a rogue couple.
Brad's going to go for Angelina.
So Brad is not within
Jen's realm of possibility.
And similarly, vice
versa-- Jen is not
in Brad's realm of possibility,
because there's no stable
matching where they're
married, in this scenario,
for this problem.
All right?
Now that we have
that notion, we can
define who your optimal mate is,
and who your pessimal mate is,
the worst case.
All right, so we define
a person's optimal mate
is his or her favorite in
the realm of possibility.
So your optimal mate is
not your favorite overall,
it's just your favorite
among those who are possible,
that there is a stable
matching that you could
be matched to that person.
And similarly, you have
a person's pessimal mate
is your least favorite from
the realm of possibility.
OK?
Because you have
all the people you
might be married to
in stable matchings.
Your favorite is the
optimal, your least favorite
is the pessimal.
Any questions about that?
Does that make sense?
And you don't count
the ones you can't
be married to, because if you
were, it would be unstable.
OK, now we can state the
blockbuster theorems here.
Theorem four says
TMA marries every boy
with his optimal mate.
Theorem five,
probably can guess,
TMA marries every girl
with her pessimal mate.
All right, so it is
optimal for every boy.
They get the best possible they
could have in stable marriages,
and every girl gets the
worst possible mate.
Now, you wouldn't necessarily
think that when you first
look at that algorithm, where
the boys are working down
their list, and the girls are
just getting better and better.
But that's the case.
Now, let's see, I'm not going
to have time to prove them both,
but I will prove theorem five.
And I'm going to
assume theorem four is
true to prove theorem five.
Maybe we'll do theorem four
tomorrow in recitation.
I don't know.
So let's do theorem five so
you can see how this works.
The proof is by
contradiction, so we'll
assume theorem four
is true, and we'll
prove the proof of theorem
five by contradiction.
So assume there was a stable
matching where a girl got
worse off than in TMA.
All right?
Assume three and
five is not true,
then there's some girl
in some stable matching.
So suppose, for the
purpose of contradiction,
that there exists
a stable matching,
we'll call it M,
where some girl,
and she fares worse than in TMA.
I want to show that
results in a contradiction.
And the proof is pretty
simple, just a simple picture.
So G did worse in M than in TMA.
All right, so let's let B
prime be the mate of G in M.
So girl G did worse in M than
in TMA, so here's her mate in M,
and let B be her mate in TMA.
Who does she like
better, B or B prime?
B, because we're saying that
she did worse in M than she did
in TMA, so she likes B better.
And let G prime be the mate
of B in M. Now, who does
B like better, G or G prime?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Not G prime.
B got married to G prime in M,
but what does theorem four say?
Yeah, G. Theorem four
says that across all
the stable matchings, B gets
his favorite mate in TMA.
So G prime is in the realm
of possibility, and so is G,
and we know from
theorem four B likes G
best, better than G prime,
because of theorem four.
So what happened here?
There's a rogue couple in M. B
and G are a rogue couple in M.
And that means that
M is not stable,
and that is a contradiction.
All right?
And so theorem five
is true, because we
assumed we had a stable
matching M where there's
a girl who did worse off.
So it really pays off to be
aggressive party in courtship.
Everybody lives
happily ever after,
especially the boys in TMA.
Now, TMA arises in
lots of applications.
The most famous is
the matching program
that's used to match MDs
to residency programs.
So how many pre-meds are here?
There's one, at least.
So you're going to go to
medical school some day,
and at the end of
medical school,
there's a big day
called match day,
where you get assigned to a
hospital for your internship,
and the way that works
is using this algorithm.
And who do you suppose is
the boy in this algorithm?
AUDIENCE: The hospital.
PROFESSOR: The hospital.
And they want it so that
when they make the matchings,
that there's not some pair of an
intern or doctor in a hospital
where they'd like each other
better than what they got.
This is used in online dating
for the obvious reasons,
and we actually use this
algorithm lot at Akamai
to load balance
traffic on the web.
And here you have the
boys are web servers,
and the girls are
requests for service.
And the goals are to
balance performance,
getting a server that's
nearby you that's fast.
And on the other side,
our cost, and by who
we make a boy and a girl, we can
trade off cost for performance
in a very nice, distributed way.
All right, so
that's it for today.